- Welcome everyone. My
name is Priya Natarajan
and I'm the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and Humanities.
I'm delighted to invite
you all to this evening's
wonderful event as part of our
distinguished author series.
First, I would like to start
by recognizing our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
and their support of the Franke Program,
Yale's flagship interdisciplinary program,
as well as multiple other initiatives
at Yale that they support.
So I wanna remind you
that as Ty mentioned,
we have a wonderful reception
upstairs after the talk.
So please do stay for that.
It's in the student lounge room 131.
And since we are recording this talk,
I'm required to read this out to you
that Yale University's photographing
and videotaping this event.
There's a possibility
that you may be included
in these visuals by being
present during these activities.
You consent to the use of your appearance,
likeness and voice by Yale University
for standard non-profit,
educational, news-related,
promotional and or editorial purposes.
So today we're in for a real
treat from one of our own
distinguished faculty,
professor Beverly Gage,
who is a professor of
history and American studies.
Her research interests lie
in 20th century U.S. history,
government and political development,
and ideological movements.
She teaches a wide variety
of extremely popular courses
that focus on American
politics, government,
and social movements.
Today she will be talking
to us about her new book,
"G-Man J. Edgar Hoover
"and the Making of the American Century."
This book has done incredibly well.
It's completely unsurprising
if you have opened up and read,
started even reading the
first couple of pages.
The writing is brilliant,
the analysis is incisive.
I highly recommend getting a copy
if you don't already have it.
So G-Man received the,
Beverly received the 2022 Bancroft Prize
in American History,
and was named a best book of 2022
by "Washington Post" in
their list of 10 best books,
"The Atlantic," in their 10 best books,
"Publishers Weekly,"
in their 10 best books.
The list is very long, but
I'll read some of them,
just to show how spectacularly
successful Beverly
has managed to reengage us
with this very complicated man
all over again.
So "The New Yorker" in
their 24 essential reads,
the "New York Times" in
their 100 notable books,
and in the "Smithsonian" in
their 10 best history books.
She's also the author of "The
Day Wall Street Exploded,
"A Story of America in
its First Age of Terror,"
which examined the history of terrorism
in the late 19th and 20th centuries,
focusing on the 1920 Wall Street bombing.
In addition to her teaching and research,
Professor Gage writes for
numerous journals and magazines,
including "The New
Yorker," "New York Times,"
and "Washington Post".
In 2009, Professor Gage received
the Sarai Ribicoff Award
for Teaching Excellence in Yale College.
In 2015, she was--
She has a very long list of honors.
I'm gonna give you like a short pressie
because I don't want take
up, you know, airtime.
So in 2015, she was elected
to serve as the first chair
of Yale's Faculty of
Arts and Sciences Senate.
From 2017 to 2021, she
served as the director
of Yale's Brady Johnson
program in Grand Strategy,
and in 2021, president
Joe Biden nominated her
to serve on the National
Humanities Council,
which is the advisory board
for the National Endowment
for the Humanities.
At Yale with Professor Elizabeth Hinton,
she leads the workshop
in modern U.S. history,
a monthly speaker series for
faculty and graduate students
to discuss the latest scholarship
in 20th century U.S. history,
and she's also deeply one of our own.
She's a graduate of Yale
University and from the American
and has a degree in American
studies and finished her PhD
at Columbia in history.
So without further ado,
I would like to turn the
floor over to Professor Gage.
Thank you so much,
Beverly, for coming today.
(applause)
- Well, thanks for that
generous introduction.
Thanks to the Franke's for
their support of this program
and to all of you for turning
out on a nice spring day
in a windowless room at
the end of the semester.
So I think the plan for today
is that I'm gonna talk for,
you know, about 40, 45 minutes and really,
just try to give you an
overview of this book
that I published in November
that is, as Priya suggested,
sort of making the rounds in the world,
and then leave time for
some real Q&A at the end.
I've found that in talking
about Jay Edgar Hoover,
who, as you will hear,
lived a very long time
and did a very many things
that my overview is useful,
but that many people come to this subject
from many different directions
and many different interests,
and have many different
points of intersection.
So I wanna make sure
that we get to the things
that interest you about Hoover,
as well as the things that interest me.
When most Americans think about
Hoover in the 21st century,
one of two images comes to mind.
The first, and I think
most prominent is of Hoover
as sort of the great
villain of the 20th century,
someone who abused
American's civil liberties,
was one of the most
manipulative, powerful,
and most hated figures
in all of Washington.
The second and slightly
more prurient set of images
that often come to mind,
they're really more a product
of the 1990s, are a set of questions
about Hoover's sexuality,
his private life,
most prominently the story
that emerged in the 1990s
that Hoover liked to
wear women's clothing.
So I'm gonna get to both aspects
of that part of his image
as we go through the talk and
as I did in the book itself.
But to start, I wanted to
present a different image.
This is Hoover's funeral in May of 1972.
He was the first civil servant ever
to lie in state at the U.S. Capitol,
and there are a couple of things
that I think are important
about starting with this image.
First, is that by the time he died,
he had been in office as
director of the FBI for 48 years.
So almost half a century.
This is a cartoon that
I reprint in the book,
and I highly recommend
picking up a copy of the book,
even if you don't buy it,
because I managed to persuade
my publisher to publish 130 photos,
which was a little bit of a struggle,
but I'm gonna show some
of them here today.
But there are a lot of good ones in there.
This is one of them, and this
is a cartoon that was done
in 1968, when Richard Nixon
was elected president,
that shows all of the different presidents
that Hoover had served under,
from Calvin Coolidge to Richard Nixon.
Hoover became head of
this little organization
known as the Bureau of
Investigation in 1924,
under Calvin Coolidge,
as you can see there.
He stayed on through the
presidency of Herbert Hoover.
So that was into the dawn
of the Great Depression,
the crises of the late
1920s and early 1930s.
He then remained for all three plus terms
of Franklin Roosevelt's presidency.
This is Roosevelt seated.
Hoover is the kind of youngish man
standing right behind him.
That's Roosevelt signing
some crime legislation.
So he stayed on through the New Deal,
the lead up to the Second World War,
and all of the Second World War.
He was then there through both terms
of Harry Truman's presidency.
So that's the dawn of the Cold War,
the years of McCarthyism.
He then stayed on through both terms
of Dwight Eisenhower's presidency,
so the tail end of
McCarthyism, the conservative,
as well as liberal politics of the 1950s.
He then stayed on through
John Kennedy's presidency.
He was there under Lyndon Johnson,
through many of the dramatic
changes in crises of the 1960s.
And then he remained under Richard Nixon
and died toward the end
of Nixon's first term,
still with the same job,
the head of the FBI.
So when I have told people
over the last decade plus
that it took me to write this book,
that I'm writing a biography
of Jay Edgar Hoover,
often their first question is,
why in the world would
you want to do that?
And I think often what
people mean by that question
is why would you want
to spend so much time
with this villain, with this terrible man,
who is reputed to have and in fact,
did so many terrible things?
And one piece of that answer
is simply this sweep of time
that Hoover was there for so long,
doing so many different things,
that he's not only
interesting in his own right
as an individual, but is
interesting to me as a vehicle
into some larger story about
20th century American politics,
and I think tells us some
things that aren't as evident
when we look in other places.
So I just wanna mention
a few of those things
and a few of those big themes
that I tried to emphasize in this book,
and then I'm gonna run
pretty efficiently I think,
through the book as a whole,
and then open this up for Q&A.
So one thing that I think that we can see,
when we look at Hoover as a vehicle
for thinking about the 20th century,
rather than some other ways of
thinking about our politics,
is a story that's as much about government
as it is about politics.
My book is called "G-Man,"
which stands for government man,
and it's called that because
that was the nickname
for FBI agents beginning in the 1930s.
So it's a catchy title in that sense,
but it also conveys
one of these big themes
that I try to get across,
which is that this is a
story that is about politics,
but it's about governance
and in particular,
it's about the growth of the state,
the federal government over
the course of the 20th century.
When Hoover became director
of the FBI in 1924,
it was this little organization
known as the Bureau of Investigation.
There were a few hundred agents,
they didn't actually
have a whole lot to do.
By the time he died in 1972,
he had about 16,000 employees.
The FBI's jurisdiction
had expanded dramatically,
and the size of the federal
government as a whole,
had expanded really dramatically.
I think when we look at our
political history, very often,
certainly in public
discourse to some degree,
in the historical profession as well,
there tends to be a lot of
emphasis on political parties,
political figures, elections, ideology,
and Hoover's part of that story,
but he sort of turns our lens
toward the administrative
state, toward this vast world
of executive power and
administrative power
that really operates outside
of electoral control,
in many ways, and that in
some ways becomes, I think,
the bigger story of the 20th century,
or at least one of the most significant
political stories there,
and within that, Hoover is a
really interesting character.
He is someone who was
really interesting to me,
as an ideological figure,
because I think he represents
two strains of our political story
that we don't often see
combined very well together.
One is that he was,
from his earliest years,
really a true believer in
this vision of federal power,
in what we might describe
as a kind of progressive
or liberal vision of state power
that involved professionalism,
that involved nonpartisan service,
that involved career
service to the government,
that involved the use
of science and expertise
to serve the public good.
And on the other hand, he was
throughout this whole time,
a really deep ideological
conservative on questions of race,
on questions of religion, on
questions of law and order,
and above all, on anti-communism,
which is really the big
theme of Hoover's life.
And I think, you know, what
fascinated me about his story
and what we don't see very often,
I think in our own politics today,
is the combining of these
two traditions into a career
that lasted for a very, very long time.
In the book, I characterized
him as something
called a conservative state builder,
but someone who essentially used the tools
of the liberal state,
including the New Deal,
which is really the moment
that the FBI gets its power,
but used those tools
really to serve a variety
of conservative causes in the end
and made those two pieces work together.
So that's sort of the
political puzzle of the book.
And then of course,
one of the other things
that drew me to Hoover
was simply the opportunity
to reinterpret a figure that
actually hadn't been revisited
in a very long time.
There were about 30 years have passed
since the last round
of Hoover biographies.
And even when I started working
on this book, which was,
I will admit, in 2009,
so about 13 years ago,
even then, it was clear not only
that Hoover was in many ways,
ripe for reinterpretation, but
that there were a whole host
of new files that had
come out about Hoover
and it seemed like an
opportunity to delve into those,
in particular, files that
had come out since the end
of the Cold War, that
I think really help us
to rethink some of the ways
that we narrate the struggles
over communism and anti-communism
in the 20th century.
But lots of other files
that have come out as well,
some of them through the
Freedom of Information Act,
some of them files that I myself,
acquired through the
Freedom of Information Act,
others that were released
in a routine way by the FBI.
So I am, you know, in my core,
really a kind of archive
nerd, a history nerd.
I love sitting there with
these giant piles of files,
trying to figure out things
that we didn't know before.
And I will say, the amount
of information available
about a figure like Hoover
is both part of the appeal
of writing this book, which
I will warn those of you
who haven't seen it, is
about 800 pages long.
And of course, is one of the
big challenges of doing it.
How do you not read absolutely everything,
but read enough to find out things
that are really new and interesting?
And of course, in Hoover's
case, that basic problem
of expansive but limited research,
is complicated by the
fact that he ran a very,
very secretive bureaucracy,
and so many of those files are,
even today, 51 years after his death,
are still redacted, are hard to access,
are hard to figure out.
So I'd be happy to talk more
about that research project
as it evolved over the
period that I worked on it
when we get to the Q&A.
But all told, those variety of factors,
the political puzzle that's available,
Hoover as a vehicle into
so many different things
over the course of the 20th century,
and then the wealth of new
material that was available,
made me think that this was a good moment
to revisit this figure
that I think has been,
and still is, a household name,
but who has been a pretty
one-dimensional figure
in lots of ways.
And my goal in writing a
biography of him was not only
to intervene in this set
of academic conversations,
but to really sort of take
him from where he's been,
which is this one-dimensional figure,
sort of seen as this rogue
actor in American history,
and really bring him back
into a more complicated story
about the 20th century
and really bring him back
into the center of
things and to the center
of a political story
about this period of time.
Because while we tend to
think of him as someone
that everyone loves to hate,
there are very few people
in our own day and age
who want to claim a figure like Hoover.
Nonetheless, during his lifetime,
he was enormously popular,
he was enormously
influential, and of course,
any one of those presidents,
all eight of them,
four Democrats, four Republicans,
could have fired him at
any moment and did not.
And so the story of his
longevity, his popularity,
the sources of his support,
is also a piece of his story
that I wanted to tell in this book,
and I think in many ways,
maybe the most counterintuitive
piece of that story,
given how widely hated and
condemned he is in our own day.
So I wanted to take a few minutes now
and just put a little more
detail onto this story of Hoover,
run relatively quickly through
the sections of the book
so you can get a sense of
the kind of amazing scope
of his life, the variety
of things that I touch upon
in the book, and then,
as I said, hopefully,
we can just open this up for conversation.
So this is a real, you know,
birth to death biography.
I found that in writing a biography,
one of the advantages
of the biographical form
is that it does give you a place to start
and a place to end, and
that's what I have done.
I did not try to upend
the biographical form.
And these are some of
the earliest pictures
we have of Hoover.
I should note this is
the only actual photo
of Hoover doing what?
Wearing a dress, his baby photo.
But Hoover is a child of Washington, D.C..
He was born in Washington D.C.
in 1895, and he never left.
He's born there in 1895.
He dies there in 1972.
And his biography really is a
story about Washington D.C.,
what that city meant and how it changed
over the course of his lifetime.
And during his early years,
I think there are two themes
that are really important
for his future development.
The first is that he was born
into a world of government service.
He was born on Capitol Hill,
just a few blocks behind the U.S. Capitol,
and he was born into
a family that already,
in the late 19th century,
had decades of service
to the federal government in
the sort of professionalized
and of the executive
branch in the few places
that really were part of
the federal Civil Service
at that point, right?
The government in the late 19th century,
particularly the
executive branch, is much,
much smaller and has many fewer duties
than what we are accustomed to today.
But nonetheless, Hoover's
family had been involved
in the government and it was the world
that he was born into.
His father was sort of a
mid-level civil servant,
and it was what Hoover saw all around him.
Washington D.C. as the national capital
and as the federal city
during those years,
also meant some very particular things,
the most notable of which is
that Washington D.C. residents
could not vote.
They did not join political parties,
and they could not vote,
either for their own
municipal government or
in federal elections.
So Hoover was not only
born into this tradition
of civil service, but
he was born into a world
that stood sort of proudly
apart from partisanship
that was a world of career service,
and in which he had very little access
to any sort of democratic participation.
So he never saw his parents vote,
he himself never joined a political party,
and he never voted in a single election.
So that's one piece of
the Washington tradition
that I think is really
critical for understanding
where he came from and who he became.
The other piece that's really
critical is that he was born
into Washington that was
essentially a conservative,
southern city in the late 19th century.
It was a city that was actively undergoing
a process of racial segregation,
had been a pretty multiracial city
in the mid and late 19th century,
but during his childhood,
was actively building racial barriers,
and he participated in and witnessed
and was shaped by that process.
He went to segregated public
schools in Washington D.C.
and then he went on to a
segregated private university,
George Washington University.
At the moment that he
joined federal employment
under the Wilson administration
was precisely the moment
that the federal government
was self-consciously
and actively segregating
federal employment
throughout the executive branch.
So these two pieces, this
government service tradition,
a tradition of racial conservatism,
of active segregationist processes go on
to be really important to
Hoover as he develops over time.
As I said, he went to the
Washington D.C. public schools.
He does not come from a wealthy family.
So he goes through the
public school system.
This is him here as a high school cadet.
He was a kind of star student.
We, I think, tend to think
of him as a rather plodding
and you know, fixed old man,
but he was apparently quite
the energetic, vibrant,
and ambitious young
student in high school.
He was the valedictorian of his class.
He was the cadet leader
of his high school class,
and he was also a star
debater in high school.
He, from there, went on to
a really critical period
of his life, which is
his years as a student
at George Washington
University that matter for,
I would say, three key reasons.
Number one is that in
order to earn his way
through law school at GW,
which was an undergraduate degree then,
he had to have a day job.
GW at that point, was
basically a night school
for future federal civil servants,
and most of them had
government jobs by day
and then went to GW at night.
Hoover was one of those students.
He got a job at the Library of Congress,
helping to sort through and establish
the Library of Congress
classification system,
and he learned very early
on there to build files,
to learn to classify things,
a whole set of kind of administrative
and information technology
tools that prove important.
The second is GW is his introduction
to the study of the law.
And then the third is
what you see up here,
which is that at GW,
he joined a fraternity called Kappa Alpha.
Kappa Alpha became not
only important to him
as a young man at GW, but
became the source of much
of his hiring at the FBI
in the years to follow.
Now, Kappa Alpha is a really
fascinating institution.
Something that I didn't know much about,
hadn't been written about
much before this biography.
But it turns out the Kappa Alpha
was a explicitly southern fraternity,
had been founded in 1865 in
the wake of the Civil War,
essentially to carry on the
lost cause of the white South.
Revered Robert E. Lee had very
explicit, sort of racialized,
lost cause, pro-confederate politics,
and by the time Hoover joined
in the early 20th century,
was a real meeting place of power
for segregationist southern Democrats
serving in Washington D.C..
So Kappa Alpha becomes a
place where you can see
that Hoover's racial
ideology is hardening,
really becoming much more
specific, and it's also a place
where he begins to develop
a political network
that becomes incredibly important to him,
a world of southern Democrats
and a world of access to political power.
These images are a couple
of examples of Kappa Alpha,
which he remained involved
in for all of his life.
The first one up there,
which is a novel called "The Klansman,"
which became the basis for
the film, "Birth of a Nation,"
written by a guy named Thomas Dixon,
who is one of the most famous
Kappa Alphas of Hoover's era.
He was still alive,
was this sort of famous
segregationist voice, and of course,
both the "Klansmen" and
the "Birth of a Nation"
are glorifications of the Ku Klux Klan.
"Birth of a Nation" came out while Hoover
was a college student.
His Kappa Alpha fraternity
gets together, they screen it,
they're very tightly tied into the world
of the Wilson Administration,
where that kind of politics
is holding sway, and this
continues for much of his life.
As I said, he retains a kind
of lifelong allegiance to
and alliance with Kappa Alpha,
draws a lot of the
first-generation of FBI officials,
both out of GW and Kappa Alpha.
But as you can see, this
is an image from the 1950s,
when Kappa Alpha is really
critical in popularizing
the confederate flag as
a symbol of resistance
to the civil rights movement.
And then over there,
a kind of lifetime achievement
certificate for Hoover
in the early '60s from Kappa Alpha.
I should note that they are
still around, this fraternity.
Many of these issues are still
live issues for Kappa Alpha.
So I recommend Googling Kappa
Alpha in our own present day.
I should also say they're not thrilled
with my depiction of them in this book.
I have heard from some Kappa Alphas
on those sorts of questions.
So that is his really
important, I think, you know,
formative period in college 1913 to 1917.
And then something happens
that's really important
and is one of these
kind of flukes of timing
that matters not only for Hoover,
but really for for the nation,
for the 20th century,
for the United States,
which is that he happens to
graduate from college in 1917,
at exactly the moment
that the United States
is entering the First World War.
He does not, though he had been, you know,
a cadet captain, does not go
on to serve in the military.
Instead he moves straight
into the Justice Department.
It is his first job out of
college, and he never leaves.
So he spends 48 years as head of the FBI.
Ultimately, he spends a total
of 55 years as an employee
of the Justice Department,
beginning in 1917.
He moves into the Justice Department
at another really critical
period in American history,
a period in which the
Justice Department's duties
are expanding very
dramatically with the war,
and in which they have a deep need
for sort of energetic young
lawyers to help them figure out
how to manage those new duties,
things like draft enforcement as the U.S.
is engaged in large
scale selective service
and draft for the first time.
In many ways, there are a
whole new set of speech laws
that come in during the war,
the Espionage Act and the Sedition Act,
aimed at war dissenters,
left-wingers, revolutionaries,
the Justice Department has to
figure out what to do there.
And they are also given the
task of figuring out a system
of internment for German nationals
living in the United
States and that is actually
Hoover's first set of duties
at the Justice Department,
German internment and German
registration during the war.
Again, something that goes
on to matter an awful lot.
From the moment that he
enters the federal government,
he is charged with these new
experiments in figuring out,
you know, who's dangerous,
who's not dangerous,
who belongs, who doesn't belong,
whose opinion is acceptable,
whose opinion is not acceptable,
and how are you going
to use this new legal
and administrative state
that is in the works
to police those lines.
These are some early archival
examples of his judgments
as a young lawyer about
various German cases.
Turns out that he is so good
at that, that at the age of 24,
as the war comes to an
end and these questions
of what all of this new apparatus
is going to look like and do with the war,
he gets the first big
promotion of his life,
the thing that really brings him
into the Bureau of Investigation,
and that is a promotion
to the head of something
called the Radical Division
within the Justice Department
and the Bureau of Investigation.
It's really the federal
government's first peacetime
experiment in how to conduct surveillance
of left-wing radicals
in the United States,
particularly anarchists and communists.
World War I had also, of course,
produced the Bolshevik Revolution,
had produced a whole new set of concerns
around the globe about
revolutionary sentiment,
the rise of communism,
and in the United States
helps to produce a a
pretty dramatic red scare
beginning in 1919.
Hoover is in the thick of that.
He is as a very, very young man,
one of the architects of the Palmer Raids,
which are a series of deportation
raids aimed at anarchists
and communists that take
place in late 1919 and 1920.
He spent a lot of the
rest of his career denying
that he had ever been
involved in the Palmer Raids
because they became very controversial
and sort of notorious symbols
of civil liberties abuses.
But it's clear from the archival record
that he was deeply involved,
that he helped to plan
those raids and that he learned
quite a lot very quickly
during those early years.
One is really an
introduction to the language
and set of ideas that become
the cause of his life,
which is the struggle against communism.
He's initiated into that
very early on as a young man.
He writes some of the
first official briefs
for the federal government
about the nature
of the new communist parties
forming in the United States.
He really stakes a lot
of his career in being
one of the great government
experts on communism,
and he's saying very
similar things in the 1940s,
he's saying very similar
things in the 1970s,
to what he first starts to
articulate in '19 and 1920,
during these very early years.
And then the second
piece is it's the moment
that he first comes into
contact and then conflict
with new civil liberties organizations
that are just getting their start
and that he's going to
kind of be in a dance with
for the rest of his career.
Most notably the ACLU,
which has its origins
in the First World War,
these struggles during the Red Scare.
From there, despite the
controversies of the Palmer Raids,
Hoover does get another
quick promotion in 1921.
As the democrats leave power,
the republicans come in,
Hoover manages to stay
on and gets a promotion
to become assistant director
of the Bureau of Investigation
at the age of 26, and then
in 1924, three years later,
at the rip old age of 29,
becomes the director of the
Bureau of Investigation,
which is the job that he holds
for the rest of his life.
So I've spent a long time
on Hoover's early years,
and I'm gonna move a little more quickly
through the next sections of the book
so that we can get to the Q&A,
but I think you can see
during these early years,
a lot of the themes developing
that he is going to then
learn to build upon,
to operationalize over
the course of his career
at the head of the Bureau.
And I think one of the puzzles
and interesting aspects
of a figure like Hoover
is that on the one hand,
he has a very fixed set
of ideas about government,
about race, about
communism, about religion,
that are there from the
moment he begins this work
to the moment that he dies,
they're incredibly consistent, right?
His words sound incredibly similar
over the course of that period.
And at the same time,
he is someone who is incredibly
adaptable, able to learn,
and in particular, able to
respond to and build upon crises.
And in many ways, the
story of the 20th century
is a story of various crises
that then produce big shifts
in the government, growth
of the security state,
as well as the social welfare state,
and Hoover is incredibly skilled
at adapting to those crises
and delivering on what he
thinks the people above him,
particularly in the White House,
as well as those below him,
his popular constituency want from him,
from the FBI and from the
federal government as a whole,
in those moments of crisis.
So the first part of
the book really focuses
on his early years from 1895 to 1924,
kind of getting him to the moment
of becoming head of the Bureau.
Part two then moves into
looking at the 1920s and 1930s
as the periods when he
really built the institution
that we know as the FBI.
It is very strange for us to think about,
but when Hoover came in in 1924
as this young new director of the bureau,
he really is brought in as a reformer.
He's brought in as a kind
of energetic young reformer,
trained in the law, trained
in information technology,
trained in a certain
kind of professionalism,
and his job is to professionalize
and clean up the bureau,
which has been A, kind of tiny backwater,
but B, a mess even at
that, full of corruption,
notorious for its abuses
of civil liberties.
And so when Hoover comes in,
the word is there's a new man in town.
He is a young professional,
steeped in progressive ideas
about science, about
expertise, about education,
and really, his vision when
he becomes head of the Bureau
is to remake it as a kind of
elite law enforcement agency
that is going to be a model
of these progressive era ideas
about facts and science and expertise
and education within the
world of law enforcement.
As you can see here, merit,
often he's contrasted with
figures like Sherlock Holmes,
the kind of rogue detective, right?
And Hoover's men are going
to be a different kind
of professional agent.
He promises not to do lots of things,
says they're unsuited to the
work of something like the FBI.
They're never gonna open people's mail,
they're never gonna wire tap,
they're never going to coerce
anyone into doing anything.
Of course, hmm, this changes
a little bit over time,
as you will see.
And he sets about not only kind of,
as he would describe it,
cleansing the bureaucracy,
but bringing in a new generation
of college-educated
lawyers and accountants,
who are supposed to be
these kind of shining,
white collar professional
law enforcement symbols.
Many of them come straight out
of his beloved institutions,
both George Washington
University and Kappa Alpha.
This is a newspaper feature
on the many young GW men
who are remaking the bureau
in the '20s and '30s.
The most important of those
men is this fellow here,
named Clyde Tolson.
Clyde Tolson was a graduate of GW.
He graduated a few years after
Hoover entered the Bureau
in 1928, and went on very quickly to rise
to the number two position at the Bureau
and to occupy that position
at Hoover's right hand
for the rest of his life as well.
Now, Clyde Tolson, of course,
if you know anything
about J. Edgar Hoover,
is not just the associate
director of the FBI,
but is it also in many
ways Hoover's life partner,
his social partner,
and the closest thing that
Hoover ever had to a spouse.
There are lots of, I think,
interesting things to say
about Hoover's sexuality,
and I'm happy to talk more about that.
I do write quite a lot
about it in the book,
but I'll just say a few things right now.
One is that Tolson is by far
the most important
relationship in his life.
Hoover does not get married,
he does not have children,
but he and Tolson really
relate to each other
as a social couple in the way
that you might expect that spouses would.
They not only work together,
they have all of their meals together,
they vacation together,
they socialize together,
and they're pretty widely
accepted in Washington,
New York, Florida, California,
the places that they spend
their time together as a social couple.
So there are lots of nice
scenes in the book of, you know,
Hoover and Clyde double dating
with say, Dick and Pat Nixon.
And so Hoover's life, his
private life, his social life,
his intimate life is, I would say,
a funny combination of, on
the one hand being very,
very public and open, and then of course,
having lots of secrets as well.
I'll show you a little bit
about Hoover and Tolson.
So this is one of my favorite
pictures of them together.
This is a celebration of
Tolson's 20 years at the FBI.
I think it was his 20th, it
might have been his 15th,
but one of Tolson's
anniversaries at the FBI,
and what I like about this is not only
that they're wearing matching suits
and standing in a sea of flowers,
but it looks kind of like
a wedding photo, right?
But that's the closest we have to that.
I think the more interesting
photos, and one of the places
that I really tried to access
not only their public life
together, which as I said,
is very open, right?
I mean, they're Broadway
shows and nightclubs
and vacations and all
over the place together,
the horse track, the baseball game,
but a little bit more
of their interiority.
What did any of this mean to them?
One of the best sources for that
was Hoover's private photo album.
I've reproduced some
of those photos there.
But that photo album is really filled
with fairly intimate portraits,
particularly in the '30s and '40s,
of their vacations together
in places like Miami and California.
So here's a shot
presumably taken by Tolson
of Hoover at the beach, getting dressed.
This is Tolson on a fishing
boat, a photo taken by Hoover.
And there are dozens and dozens
of these photos, you know,
really quite intimate photos,
of the two of them together.
And there are other ways to I think,
begin to get at what
they meant to each other.
But these are some of my favorite sources.
Of course then, in thinking
about Hoover and Tolson
as a couple, there are of
a couple of complications.
One, we don't know of course,
whether this was in fact a
sexual relationship or not.
Two, is that they came of age
and were deeply interested
in and involved in policing the sex lives
of other gay people, particularly
in the '40s, '50s and '60s
when it was federal policy
that you could not be gay
and be employed in the federal government.
So Hoover is on the one hand,
involved in this very public,
open, intimate social
partnership with his number two
at the FBI, and then on the other hand,
is actively policing the
sexual and private lives
of thousands of federal civil servants.
And to complicate matters
further, of course,
when anyone suggested,
as many, many people did
over the course of Hoover's life
that perhaps Hoover himself
was gay or queer or homosexual,
right, in the language of the time,
they might actually get
an FBI agent showing up
to their door, knocking on
it and saying, you know,
we've heard you've been
spreading these rumors
about the director of the FBI.
You know, we're sure you don't
want to say such scurrilous
things about the most
wonderful, important,
federal servant we've ever seen.
And of course, people
were a little frightened
in those situations, but
he really used the power
of the bureau that he created,
to police his own reputation
and to police the
boundaries of what was known
about his own intimate life.
So I'm happy to talk more
about that in the Q&A.
That relationship plays
a big role in the book.
But I wanna say a few other
things about what happens
in the '30s and '40s, as
Hoover is the head of the FBI.
And probably the most surprising thing
is that it is really during the New deal
that he ends up acquiring most
of his power and influence.
He spends a lot of the '20s and '30s,
kind of engaged in building
up the scientific end
of the bureau, the fingerprint division,
getting control of
crime statistics, right?
When you hear crime statistics today,
that's because J. Edgar
Hoover in the '30s,
demanded that the FBI be in
control of crime statistics.
So if you hear the FBI
uniform crime reports today,
that comes from Hoover's years
setting up the FBI lab,
setting up its academy,
setting up these new training facilities
to professionalize the Bureau.
During the 1920s, these are
the glamour shots of the FBI
that Hoover likes to promote.
There are sort of endless numbers of shots
of just filing cabinets, right?
Guys standing at filing
cabinets showing off
how much they know that
they are, you know,
white collar paper pushers, et cetera.
But this is Hoover's
favorite image of the Bureau
in the 1920s,
and then suddenly in the mid 1930s,
that all begins to change.
By 1935 and 1936, you're
not seeing filing cabinets,
but you're seeing the
famous images of FBI agents
with Tommy guns, as great crime fighters.
The main thing that happens in
the 1930s to produce the FBI
that we know today, is
that Franklin Roosevelt
and the state builders of
the New Deal look to the FBI
to become the sort of
federal standard bearers
for what they describe as a
war on crime in the 1930s.
So suddenly, Hoover's
nice white collar lawyers
and accountants are told,
beginning in 1934 and '35,
that they are actually going
to be gun-wielding policemen.
Some of them have no
idea how to shoot a gun.
They had no expectation that
this was going to be their job.
But in the midst of a New
Deal push to go after a wave
of kind of high-profile
kidnappers, bank robbers,
figures like John Dillinger,
you see a radical change at the FBI,
and that's where we begin to
get this very different image
and Hoover responds to
that crisis quickly.
That happens through crime legislation,
and as you can see through
some of these images,
the FBI becomes essentially,
a New Deal alphabet agency, right?
They become symbols of these
new forms of federal power
that are going to intervene,
not only in solving
the economic oppressions and
problems of the New Deal,
but are going to be much more involved
in law enforcement as well.
So here they are fighting kidnapping.
Along the way, Hoover begins
to develop what becomes
one of his signature
features as a bureaucrat,
which is his public relations division,
encouraged by Franklin
Roosevelt who says, you know,
you can't just accept
that people understand
the work of government.
You've got to sell it to them.
You've got to explain to them
what the federal government is doing.
Hoover becomes really,
a master of publicity,
Hollywood movies, newspaper
reports, et cetera,
begin to glorify him and really turn him
into a celebrity in the 1930s.
And then the last thing
that happens in the 1930s
and into the '40s is that the FBI moves
much more aggressively into the world
of domestic intelligence espionage,
in ways that are fundamentally new.
And it's under Franklin Roosevelt
that the FBI really begins
to do the work that we
associate with it today,
on the one hand,
to be a federal criminal
law enforcement agency,
and on the other hand,
to be our domestic intelligence agency
dealing with things like espionage,
and in particular with
political intelligence,
surveillance and kind of
mass political surveillance.
The other thing that happens
by the end of the war
is that the FBI has quadrupled in size.
So Hoover started out in
the 1920s with this tiny
little group of a few hundred agents,
a few hundred people in
the fingerprint division.
This is his filing cabinets
by the end of the war.
This is the Washington Armory,
the FBI moves in, and
as you can see, he now,
by the end of the war, really
has an army of his own.
So that is part two of the book,
this period of institution building
that moves from the '20s through the '40s.
I'll just say a few words
about the last two sections
of the book, which I think
in many ways are the periods
that most people today know best
when they think about Hoover,
when they think about
the FBI and its history.
The first of those is the
period in the late '40s
and into the 1950s, when I
would say Hoover has finished
a lot of building the FBI
and then puts it to work
for the causes that he cares
about most and above all,
puts them to work in the
cause of fighting communism.
They've been doing some of that work
in the '40s during the war,
but as the war comes to an end,
the Cold War begins to emerge.
Hoover very quickly becomes one
of the most prominent voices
of anti-communism in the United States.
This is the cover of "Newsweek", by 1947,
already looking to Hoover
as a national spokesman
for the anti-communist cause and really,
for trying to raise the level of alarm
in the United States around
the question of communism.
I think there are a couple of
things that are worth noting
about the way that Hoover
relates to this question
and why he's really important.
I said in the '20s, '30s, through the war,
he's really building the Bureau.
He is not doing, I think, as much
following of his own
agenda, as we begin to see
during this period when
he's really secured
the institutional heft of the FBI,
has secured his own public profile,
and then can really begin
to shape public opinion
and to shape Washington politics
in much more autonomous ways.
It is possible to imagine an
FBI director in the 1940s,
you know, faced with
the emerging Cold War,
who takes a pretty narrow view
of national security, right,
says that I am, you know, a
federal law enforcement agent
and the head of our
domestic political police,
but in that role,
my job is to look into
questions of espionage,
perhaps to keep an eye
on the communist party,
which is in fact, you know,
cooperating with Soviet
agents during these years,
both around espionage and is taking money
from the Soviet Union, and
that's where my job ends, right?
That's what a national security
and law enforcement profile looks like.
Hoover sort of does the opposite.
He does that kind of work,
and there's lots of
interesting stuff to say
about the big espionage
cases of those years,
but he makes himself a
kind of cultural icon,
a political force in defining the struggle
against communism in the
broadest ways possible.
So to Hoover, you know, it is
not only a matter of espionage
or of containing the role
of the communist party,
but he really frames anti-communism
as an existential struggle
that involves every person
in the United States, and that
is constantly being fought
out in every institution
in the United States,
from universities to public schools,
to churches, to the government itself,
and that involves every
aspect of people's lives,
from race relations to religion,
to family structure, and on and on.
And so he's engaged in a lot
of very kind of technical
investigations on the one hand,
and then on the other hand,
he's pouring out a whole series
of books, articles, films,
framing the communist question
in very dramatic, and as I
said, sort of existential ways.
Couple of other things to
note about this period.
One is that it's a period when he begins
to work very closely with
congressional committees,
especially committees
like the House Committee
on American Activities,
the Senate Internal Security Subcommittee,
congressional committees that are involved
in the kind of work that he cares about.
One of my favorite chapters in the book
is about his starting in the 1940s,
as a variety of these committees
need professional staff,
to agree to start staffing
them with FBI agents.
And so he gets this very
dramatic inroad into Congress.
The Appropriations Committee, HUAC,
a whole series of committees
end up staffed by FBI agents,
which means he has access
to lots of information,
lots of influence, and lots
of important ties to Congress,
just one symbol of his bureaucratic skill.
This is Hoover testifying
in front of Congress in 1953
in the Harry Dexter White spy case.
The other is his relationship
to Joseph McCarthy.
So this is a photo of a vacation photo
with Hoover and Tolson.
Let's see, Hoover's over here on my left.
Tolson is the second one
from the right there,
and that's Joe McCarthy on the end.
So they're all vacationing
together out in California.
In some ways they are social friends,
they obviously share a set of
anti-communist commitments,
but what was more interesting
to me were the ways
in which Hoover and
McCarthy ultimately diverge.
Hoover becomes seen
popularly in the White House,
as well as among liberals,
as the more responsible
alternative to Joe McCarthy,
who ends up depicted as
the kind of demagogue,
the loose cannon, the liar.
So in our minds, I think
these two were often
kind of conflated together,
but in the politics of their moment,
they were seen as very
different sorts of figures.
And in fact, it's Hoover
that many liberals end up
rallying behind as sort of an
alternative to Joe McCarthy.
I'll just show a few examples,
as well of Hoover's
broader cultural impact.
So this is, you know, a bus bench.
I think it's in Houston, is
that what it says up there?
At any rate, I said
that Hoover was not only
this kind of technocrat,
but this significant popular
and cultural figure.
This is him fighting communism.
He wrote a bestseller
called, "Masters of Deceit"
that many people were forced
to read as young children,
telling you how you could participate
in the fight against communism.
This is Hoover lecturing American families
about how to raise their
children, which, you know,
people would occasionally
point out they're not sure
where he gets his
expertise on that question.
And then finally, in the '50s, as I said,
Hoover's this important cultural
figure on anti-communism,
but he also becomes a very sort
of outspoken religious voice
and plays a big role in the
kind of surge of religiosity
that's so important to
the conservative politics
of the 1950s.
All right, I will finish up very quickly,
just with the period of the
'60s and '70s, which as I said,
I think are the most familiar
to many people today,
and really are the period
when Hoover becomes,
if not a less influential figure,
a less universally popular figure.
By the late 1950s, his popularity ratings
are in the 70s, 80s, 90 percentiles.
That begins to fall off a
little bit in the 1960s,
as the country's politics
change and as he ages.
So the last part of the book
is this period from 1960
up to his death in 1972.
That covers what I think, are
three of the most interesting
presidential relationships in the book.
The first is his relationship
with the Kennedy administration.
And what I love about this picture
is that I think it sort of
captures that relationship,
which it was not a happy one.
They really didn't like each other.
And John Kennedy is one of those figures
who might have fired Hoover.
He certainly thought about it.
He considered it and thought
that it was not a good idea
for a variety of reasons.
Hoover was particularly
hostile to Bobby Kennedy,
who of course was made Attorney General
under his brother's presidency
at a fairly young age.
I found myself actually
surprisingly sympathetic to Hoover,
who is in his early 60s, that is saying,
why is there this 35 year
old attorney general?
He doesn't seem very qualified,
and I don't really like him.
But at any rate,
theirs is an interesting
relationship as well.
It then goes on to Hoover's relationship
with Lyndon Johnson, and I
think we would tend to think
of Hoover and Johnson as
being on opposite sides
of things like civil rights,
other major political trends of the 1960s,
Johnson as a great liberal icon,
Hoover increasingly can seen
as a far right conservative,
but actually they got along really well
and they cooperated in pretty dramatic
and often quite outrageous
ways in the 1960s.
They had been neighbors on
the same block in Washington,
so they knew each other
from the 1940s onward,
and it's really Lyndon Johnson
that we can thank or blame
for making J. Edgar Hoover,
essentially FBI Director for life.
Had things gone their normal course,
Hoover would've been forced
to retire at the age of 70.
That would've been January 1st, 1965.
But Lyndon Johnson decided to exempt him
from the mandatory federal retirement age.
And this is the ceremony in 1964,
where Johnson says that he
wants Hoover to stay on.
Now, why did Johnson
want Hoover to stay on?
It's an interesting
question, but as I said,
they had this longstanding relationship,
and also Johnson went on to use Hoover
and the FBI more aggressively
than almost any other president.
Sometimes that was in the service
of civil rights enforcement.
Johnson really pushed the
FBI to be more aggressive
about civil rights enforcement,
particularly after the civil
rights legislation of that era.
But he also used the
FBI pretty aggressively
to police the civil rights
movement, to police the left.
One of the more outrageous
moments is when Johnson
asks the FBI to conduct
surveillance wiretapping
infiltration of civil rights demonstrators
at the 1964 Democratic National
Convention on his behalf
and to report back to him
what was going on there
with the Mississippi
Freedom Democratic Party.
At any rate, there's a lot
about Hoover and Johnson.
It's a really interesting, complicated,
and I think counterintuitive
relationship in many ways.
And there's a lot about
Richard Nixon as well,
which is probably the most long-standing
and closest presidential
relationship of Hoover's life.
They too, had been very
close since the 1940s.
This is them vacationing
together, as well in the 1950s,
but they run into some conflicts
when Nixon becomes president
and theirs is an interesting
and complicated relationship as well.
That section of the book also
goes into a lot of the big
investigations of the era,
most notably the Kennedy assassination
and the King assassination.
I should say, in writing the
book, there were a few sections
that I really dreaded having to get into.
Those were among them because
the volume of material
related to those cases is so vast.
The literature related
to those cases is so vast
and so much of it is so
bizarre and terrible,
and I had to wade into that.
But the real thrust of this final section
is about Hoover's political
policing in the 1960s,
particularly the FBI's campaigns
against the civil rights
movement, against the new left,
and against figures
like Martin Luther King,
in which the FBI conducted not only
a pretty aggressive public
campaign to discredit King
and destabilize the movement,
but also a whole series
of pretty outrageous secret activities,
including wiretapping King's
home and office phones,
planting bugs in his hotel
rooms to record his sex life,
sending those recordings to King,
along with anonymous threatening notes,
and deploying those sorts of
tactics, not only against King,
but against a wide variety
of figures on the left,
as well as to some degree,
on the right as well.
Probably the most famous of
those programs in the 1960s
is a program known as COINTELPRO,
which was started in the
late '50s as a program
aimed at the Communist Party,
expanded over the course of the 1960s,
to become a program of
surveillance and disruption
aimed at nearly every
organization on the left,
from the civil rights movement
to the Black Panthers,
to student activists.
It was a program that involved
not only surveillance,
wire tapping, et cetera, but
active disruptive techniques,
sending in informants to disrupt meetings,
planting false newspaper allegations,
working with local police
to set up activists for arrest, et cetera.
It's worth noting here
that most of this was aimed
at the politics of the
left, but the FBI did employ
some of those techniques
against the Ku Klux Klan,
against neo-Nazi organizations,
white supremacist
organizations in the 1960s.
So I think even in this period, you know,
Hoover has a more complicated
story than is often portrayed
in the public discourse,
although, you know,
the basic thrust of COINTELPRO
as a pretty destructive,
outrageous, and illegal program
that had a dramatic effect
on the civil rights
movement in particular,
but the new left more broadly,
I think is basically correct.
And then we end up back here
in 1972 with Hoover's funeral.
As I said, he sort of
died with his boots on
as FBI director in May of 1972.
And at the moment that he died,
there was a lot of celebration
among those who hated him.
But I would say more broadly, you know,
reflection on the fact
that whatever you thought
of what he had accomplished,
he had been really a central
figure in the politics
of the 20th century, a
central figure in the politics
of Washington over that time period,
and as Richard Nixon said
in his eulogy for Hoover,
one of the giants of American history.
And so my goal in writing this
book was to sort of take him
from what I think he had
become in the 21st century,
which is sort of a
one-dimensional caricature
and bring him back into the
center of this politics,
where he had his hands in so much,
but where he wasn't
just acting on his own,
he was acting in concert with many figures
in the White House, with
many figures in Congress,
and was an enormously kind of popular
and influential public servant,
for better or for worse.
So I will leave my remarks there.
I'm happy to, you know, take questions
in whatever form you think makes sense,
Ty?
- Yeah, sure.
Well, first of all...
(applause)
- Thank you.
- Wonderful talk on a great subject.
I just finished rereading "1984".
COINTELPRO, by the way,
is a great new speak word.
First to me, right.
Maybe that wasn't lost on Hoover,
and of course, Orwell is
preoccupied with the idea
that technological
advancements would be developed
and employed in this surveillance
and the advancement of
surveillance of individual citizens
and like the tele screens novel.
So you talked a bit about
Hoover's ideas on science,
which you described as...
What were they, could you give us an idea,
what they were and how
did they figure into
for surveillance and his work at the FBI?
- Yeah, great.
That's a really important question,
and it's a big theme of his career.
So when he became director in the 1920s,
he advertised himself as
kind of one of the great
expositors of something
called scientific policing.
And scientific policing
was supposed to make police
more effective, and as
Hoover would've described it,
less brutal at the same time.
So what scientific policing really meant
was a couple of things.
One was harnessing a new
set of social science tools
that could be put to the
work of law enforcement.
So that was everything
from new classification
and filing systems to
things like fingerprints,
which are just coming in
as a form of identification
to crime statistics.
Right, there was no, I mean,
in the 1920s into the early '30s,
there's a lot of talk about this
as a crisis in the United States,
but there were no
national crime statistics
being gathered in any effective way.
So you had perceptions of
growing forms of crime.
You have new things like the
automobile and the machine gun
coming in as tools that
are allowing first,
greater degrees of violence in some ways,
but are allowing criminals
to cross federal lines,
cross state lines.
And so there are all sorts
of technological changes
that are then driving this
push for crime statistics.
So Hoover is very serious
about wanting to get control
of crime statistics because he
saw it as one of these places
where the FBI could be effective
as a rather small organization.
It could be in touch with
every police department
in the country in order to
collect these statistics.
And so that was going to be important
for his kind of institutional influence.
And then it was gonna
allow him to influence
and define what crime
was, how it was counted,
as well as what public
perceptions would be.
So scientific policing is on the one hand,
this set of kind of professionalizing
and social science tools that
includes the FBI Academy,
and then on the other hand,
there's this whole world
of forensic science that is
just starting to open up.
So fingerprints fit over
there as well a little bit.
But one of his signature developments
in the early '30s is the FBI crime lab,
which is still the FBI crime
lab that we know today,
which has had its own sort of failures
and scandals over the last 20 years,
but his vision was that
he was gonna employ,
you know, a bunch of
chemists and scientists
who would be able to be the
nation's top forensic experts,
so that when local
police ran into problems,
they could send their
evidence into the FBI,
the FBI could help them to
figure out what was going on,
and they would get that
information back down
to the local police level.
Because of course, in our
country, almost all to this day,
almost all law enforcement
is done at the local level,
and so to be a federal
law enforcement agency
or even a federal intelligence agency,
but in law enforcement in particular,
Hoover always had this problem,
which is that relative to
the scope of the country,
the FBI was tiny,
and that it didn't have
actually a lot of jurisdiction,
or it had very weird
areas of jurisdiction,
and that is still true today.
And so he saw these not only as places
of kind of scientific progress,
but he also saw them as
sort of strategic points
of intervention, a role
that the Bureau could play.
And I think it's still
a really important part
of the FBI's image, this
kind of, you know, I mean,
how many television shows do we still have
that are about you know,
kind of elite forensics labs
that are often at the federal level,
that are doing the work
that Hoover envisioned.
- [Speaker] Did Hoover
seem to run off the rails
in the '60s?
And do you think that the student protests
had anything to do with that?
- Yeah, the '60s were
definitely the period
in which I think what he
had built up in the '50s,
which was very bipartisan support
and very widespread public support,
really begins to fracture.
And a lot of it has to do with, you know,
his attitudes toward and public campaigns
against student activists,
the civil rights movement.
Right, I think he took a
lot of what he had done,
both in terms of formal techniques
and in terms of publicity
with the communist party in the '50s,
and kind of transferred
that over to the new left
into the social movements of the '60s.
But of course, the communist
party wasn't very popular
in the 1950s, whereas those movements
actually had real popular constituencies,
a lot of, you know, a lot of
people who supported them,
and so it didn't, his
formula suddenly didn't work
in the 1960s.
So some of that I think,
was generational, right?
He was getting much older.
He seemed much more sort of out of touch
with the new generations of students.
Some of it was that he
sort of couldn't get out
of a sort of Cold War mentality.
So he is constantly
accusing Martin Luther King
of being a communist,
accusing student activists
of being tools of the communists, right,
the anti-war movement,
and it didn't work as well in the '60s.
And then I think there was
also just a sort of changing
civil liberties
consciousness in that decade,
where techniques that were
once deemed, you know,
tolerable or acceptable, you know,
you were really seeing a
different set of assessments
about individual rights,
about civil liberties.
And so a lot of Hoover's techniques,
as well also came under a lot
more, a lot more scrutiny.
- [Speaker] I was gonna ask
what sources gave you, like,
it sounds like he was a
very political person,
and I'm wondering where you
felt like you got the most frank
and honest access to his
voice and his thinking
and his mind in correspondence
or anything else?
- Well, I think there are a
couple of different things
that come to mind.
So one is, are the FBI files themselves,
which as I said, have all
sorts of problems, right?
They're police files,
and so they have certain,
you know, obvious biases, et cetera.
They also are often redacted,
so you can't find out
everything that's in them.
My personal favorite file on
that front is the FBI's file
on the CIA, which, you
know, has page after page.
where they say, you know, Dear Director,
the most interesting thing happened today,
and then it's all just black, right?
So you can't actually have access
to any page after page of redaction.
But the advantage of those FBI files
is that during Hoover's lifetime,
he believed that no one
else would ever have access.
There was no Freedom of Information Act.
There were no congressional
intelligence committees.
And in fact, there was no
mechanism aside from the courts,
which occasionally cost, you know,
forced the FBI to cough something up.
Hoover believed he had total
control over those files,
and therefore, they're
pretty candid in these files,
both about, you know,
when you read their files
on Martin Luther King and what
they're plotting against him,
and they just write it all down.
And that's true in many, many instances.
And then Hoover himself,
had a habit of writing
things in the margins.
So he had a blue pen,
he could write things in the margins,
and so he's just scrawling
all of these often, you know,
kind of epithets and his
true opinions of many people.
So those I actually think
are pretty direct access.
And then the most direct and
literal access to his voice
are the Johnson and Nixon tapes,
which are really interesting
because he had very close
relationships with both of them.
Lots of their phone
conversations are recorded
and you listen to them
and they are talking
about a vast array of things.
And yeah, and they're often pretty frank
with each other in those.
- [Speaker] I'm not
sure if you're familiar
with the organization
that's called The Family,
that there's been a lot written
about it over the years.
And you know, they claim
that Supreme Court justices
and senators.
In your research, did
you find any connection
between Hoover and The Family?
- I didn't find direct connections,
and I'm sort of generally familiar
with The Family without
knowing all of the specifics.
But Hoover's relationship with the right,
and with right wing
organizations and with, you know,
a certain kind of nascent religious right
that's beginning to
emerge during his lifetime
was really interesting to me.
Though, a lot of the kind
of conservative movement
that starts in the '50s and into the '60s
kind of takes aim at
federal bureaucrats, right,
as the worst people in the world,
is anti-statist in lots of ways, right?
A kind of Buckley-ite critique
of the federal government.
Hoover was always the one federal servant,
lifetime career bureaucrat
that they loved,
and one of the places that this emerges
pretty dramatically is with
the John Birch Society, right,
which in many ways is kind of a forerunner
of the sorts of organizations
that you're talking about.
John Birch Society, far
right, kind of grassroots,
anti-communist organization in
the late '50s and early '60s.
And the John Birch Society
loves Hoover, right.
They are constantly assigning his books.
They're sort of saying, you
know, the great authority,
J, Edgar Hoover says, you know,
the Communist menace is here
and it will never go away,
and we all have to participate in this.
But Hoover himself was
actually pretty skeptical
of groups like the John Birch Society
because he thought they were extremists,
they were a little out of control,
and so there's a real ambivalence there.
So, you know, I think
that that would be sort of
his relationship with an
organization like The Family.
The only other thing that I would say
is that Hoover was himself, you know,
I think he considered himself
a kind of deeply religious Christian.
He didn't go to church all that
often, from what I can tell,
but he spoke often,
particularly in the 1950s,
about the need for religiosity.
He had, you know, send all
your children to Sunday school.
He had been a Sunday school teacher,
and I think institutionally,
he then begins to bring a
lot of that into the FBI.
So he begins to hire Mormons
in much greater numbers
and Catholics in much greater
numbers in the '50s and '60s,
and he begins to bring a set
of kind of religious rituals,
communion breakfasts, prayer
breakfasts into the FBI itself.
So there are ways in which
he's doing some of that similar
kind of work within the Bureau itself.
- [Speaker] So it sounds
like with the religious part
of his life, lukewarm as maybe it was,
there's that dichotomy again,
between what he is portraying
or what he's advocating for, right,
and what he's really living.
Same thing with, "If I Had
a Son", was that the book?
Looking at his photo
album and his writings,
the marginalia that you
surely pored over for years,
what is your sense of
where he was mentally
with that dichotomy?
Is it, this is self aggrandizement
for career advancement,
or he could, he was
skillfully enough to occupy
both spheres and do it, you know,
to his bureaucratic success where,
I mean, how did he square that?
- That's a great question,
and I'm not sure I found
the final answer to that question.
- Got lucid.
- Right, right.
There's one of my favorite
discoveries that helped me
get a little sense of that
maybe is that in 1950,
he was on vacation with
Clyde Tolson in Los Angeles,
and a reporter started
following them around.
They didn't see the
reporter, but you know,
they went to the farmer's market together.
They went and got ice
cream cones together,
and then they went to a bookstore,
and this reporter was following them,
and the reporter looked at the
books that they were buying,
and Tolson was buying
a couple of westerns,
you know, beach reading.
But Hoover was buying two
books by a psychoanalyst
named Karen Horney, who
was a famous psychoanalyst
of that period, wrote popular books.
Her papers are actually here at Yale,
and one was called, "Our Inner Conflicts,"
and the other was called, "Self-Analysis."
And so I was like, I'm
gonna read these books,
and you know, the Yale
libraries being what they are,
there were Karen Horney's books.
And so in particular,
"Our Inner Conflicts"
was about precisely what you're saying,
what it does when your public image
is so radically different
from the self that you know,
and what that does to someone,
to have that kind of radical difference.
You're one thing in public,
you're another thing in private,
and you have to live with that.
And the premise of that
book was that it produced
a certain kind of grandiosity,
a certain sort of rigidity,
and a kind of hyper policing
of your public image
and of those around you, right,
a heightened need for control, et cetera.
And it was kind of remarkable.
So I don't know if we can
take this and therefore,
apply it directly to Hoover,
although there were a
lot of features of that
that did resonate with who he was.
But what was interesting
to me is that it seemed
that he himself, was
actually trying to sort out
that question, right,
in ways that he couldn't
speak about publicly.
Maybe he spoke about with friends,
maybe it had to do with his sexuality.
I mean, some of it must have had to do
with his sexuality, but there
were other aspects of his life
where that applied as well.
So all I can say is that, you know,
there are glimmers that he
was asking those questions,
even if they never quite got reconciled.
- [Speaker] I think it's
fascinating that the
concept of the deep state
is living with us to become new,
and it seems like that
his role in creating
what now people think
of as the deep state,
was so, or what do you think
about his sort of ongoing
legacy or both with the
nation and with the right?
- Yeah, so one of the things
that's been really fascinating
to me over the last five years,
really during the Trump era,
is to see a kind of dramatic
reversal in what we got,
really from the end of Hoover's life
up until fairly recently,
which is politics in which,
you know, in the wake of Hoover's death,
and then the church committee
investigations of the 1970s,
which were investigations
into the FBI, the CIA,
that really produced some
of the knowledge we have
about all of their abuses
over the course of the
20th century, right?
In that moment, coming out of the 1960s,
you had a pretty consistent
set of political sentiments
in which democrats, liberals, and leftists
were much more critical
of the FBI in particular,
than republicans, conservatives, right.
Republicans and conservatives
tended to love the FBI,
democrats, liberals, progressives
be very suspicious of it.
And today that has
flipped very dramatically
and some of that simply
has to do with, you know,
the Trump era investigations themselves,
I think has to do with,
you know, a broader sense
that the part of the FBI that
is in fact about, you know,
fact finding and expertise
and law enforcement is itself,
worth protecting in a
period when, you know,
facts seem to be up for debate.
But, so now we have, as you're saying,
a situation in which, you know,
a lot of the most vocal
deep state critiques
are coming from the right,
and I think you can see
a little bit of that
during Hoover's years.
I mean, particularly among
white supremacist groups
in the white South, there's
always a lot of resistance
to federal authority, to the FBI.
And so I think you can see
some of those strains coming out now.
And of course, there's always been
a sort of libertarian
critique of the security state
of federal surveillance, the deep state.
But, but yeah, it seems
very consistent now.
There's no question Hoover
is an architect of that,
and some of that politics
come out of his era, you know,
James Comey, blurbed
the book, read the book,
and is someone that I've
had a few conversations with
over the years about Hoover and, you know,
both looking at him from the outside
and then just speaking
with him a little bit
about these issues, you
know, I do think that the FBI
has also often been in a
very difficult position,
where it's situated in
the executive branch.
It is supposed to be
nonpartisan, fact-finding right,
outside of politics, and yet
again and again in its history,
it gets dragged into these
incredibly politicized
investigations, incredibly
partisan situations,
where it's legitimately quite difficult
to figure out what to do, right.
Hoover had that experience quite often,
especially in the '60s around
the major assassinations,
later on for the FBI around Watergate.
And I think you can see
exactly that structural tension
at play right now, and it
so happens that, you know,
it's playing out in a very
particular partisan way
at the moment.
But yes, defund the FBI is
not coming from the left
in this moment, right?
It is a right wing slogan.
- [Speaker] He was in power,
you said, for 48 years.
How do you think he maintained
that power so consistently?
And number two is, you
mentioned President Kennedy
wanting to maybe fire him.
Why do you think he did not?
- Well, I think those questions
are related to each other.
And I think the easy answer,
and probably the most popular answer
to how Hoover stayed in power for so long
was that he had the
goods on people, right,
that he had files on lots of
important people in the media,
in politics, and the
White House, in Congress,
and there is, actually,
there is some truth to that.
And it's certainly the
case with John Kennedy,
that the FBI knew an awful
lot about Kennedy's sex life.
They knew an awful lot about, you know,
kind overt action decisions
that the Kennedys had made.
They knew, for instance,
that John Kennedy shared a girlfriend
with the head of the Chicago mob, right?
So pretty, pretty compromising stuff.
And Kennedy knew that the FBI knew that.
And so, you know, I think that's
at least part of the story,
particularly in Hoover's later years,
when he has such a concentration of power.
But, you know, one of
the things that I wanted
to really bring out in the book
is that I don't think you
can understand his power
simply as this form of coercion,
because he had lots of support as well,
over the course of his career,
and he was incredibly skilled
at building that support.
So the main reason that many
presidents didn't fire him
is that he was really,
really useful to them, right?
He would do their bidding,
he would keep their secrets.
He was occasionally, you know,
resistant in ways that
they didn't appreciate,
but often was incredibly accommodating
to White House wanted done.
So he had control over his bureaucracy,
he did what presidents wanted,
and they saw value in him.
But he was also really good at, you know,
creating a popular constituency.
The FBI built up relationships
with organizations
like the American Legion,
Daughters of the American Revolution,
and they sort of, anytime
anyone critiqued the FBI,
you know, every American Legion
Post would sort of rise up
in protest about our
great heroic FBI director.
So he was very good at that.
He had a huge amount of energy
devoted to public relations
and to press relations in particular.
So had lots of columnists in his pocket
who would also rise to his defense.
And as I suggested,
in talking about congressional committees,
he was really smart
about building a series
of kind of mutually
beneficial relationships
with congressmen and
senators in particular,
a lot of whom really liked
him and really supported him.
So, to go back to Kennedy,
but I think this is indicative
of his power more broadly,
Kennedy did not like him personally.
They didn't get along that well,
but Kennedy knew that Hoover
had a lot of information,
the ability to get that information out,
and Kennedy also says
that he actually thinks
that J. Hoover is A, more popular,
and B, has a more loyal
political constituency
than Kennedy himself does.
And so, you know, they thought
Hoover was more powerful
and more popular and not a place
to waste a lot of political capital.
- [Speaker] Thank you.
- Okay and with that,
another round of applause.
(applause)
(bright music)